let's start with the electricity crisis
15 years into it we are still here I
mean the damage that load shading has
brought to this economy has been
incalculable there's no electricity the
robot is not
working for years the state electricity
provider escom has struggled with
mismanagement with inefficiency
corruption escom was at the mercy of
some very large organ
crime cartels in the case of deoa he had
been drinking coffee LC with C some of
the most daring acts of corruption have
been uncovered and the people are being
pursued hello security L shedding in a
hole needs to come to an end whenever
that's going to happen we've got no
[Music]
idea escom is the economic engine of
South Africa it provides today 80% of
all of the Power that South Africa uses
and as the Aging Coal Fired power
stations get yet older and yet more
inefficient break down yet more often
it's really struggling to keep the
lights on there isn't a lack of capacity
what there is a lack of is capacity that
is being managed
properly so for many years now South
Africa has been suffering from something
that they call here load shedding really
planned power Cuts these can be 2 hours
a day day they can be 6 hours a day they
can even be 12 hours a day this is when
whole parts of the country are blacked
out Lo setting is steing time it is
steing opportunity from Africa's most
industrialized economy it is cutting off
electricity to customers who are paying
for it in order to prevent a total
collapse of the grid the impact of load
shedding on day-to-day life in South
Africa is enormous and that could be
anything from traffic lights not working
you go to the shops and the card
machines don't work you can't make phone
calls Advanced smelters data centers
mines they're all affected the South
African Reserve Bank cut GDP growth this
year by 2% points to
0.3% it's said that low treading would
have a half a percentage points increase
on inflation because businesses have to
pass on the cost to Consumers these
things add up day after day and it
really does have quite an impressive
psychological impact as well ultimately
escom is run by the government and
ultimately the government is thec it's
run the country for 30 years if escom is
failing then in the people's minds thec
is also
[Music]
failing we actually preparing the Sheep
Drive called muodu one of our famous
dishes
you know the struggles that we
experiencing here in South Africa which
is low shedding you understand that will
be one of the topics when people just
sitting there would talk about and how
the country is being
[Music]
run we stock every day when it comes to
meat because we don't want to keep meat
in the fridge in case escom decides to
switch off the grid and then it becomes
a problem and then it's a was stage and
meat is expensive so this is the point
of sale right so when the electricity
goes off
we can't use the system at
[Music]
all I'm taking a photo and video to post
on Instagram so that people can get
hungry and come and
buy I mean when my battery is on 5% I
can't charge you understand also the
coffee machine it won't work also we
cannot even use the microwave just to
warm the food so it becomes a bit of a
struggle you know there's no music just
to entertain people so it affects us in
so so many ways yeah but we just have to
keep focused cuz we know how critical
esam is to the economy priority number
one is to continue on the recovery of
generation and reducing that intensity
of the load shedding it builds
confidence to the esam team and the
generation staff but more important the
positivity and confidence it gives to
the economy and to the citizens of the
country we're working very hard we are
burning the diesel the team is having
sleepless nights to make sure that we
improve the energy availability Factor
we have to eradicate low sheding and the
only way of doing that is to ensure that
generation exceed demand we ensure that
we improve the performance of the
existing fet which is aging but secondly
to introduce new generating capacity
largely from renewable sources of energy
there is a reality is only 24 hours in
the day you're dealing with lad shedding
you are dealing with the de relief
you're dealing dealing with unbundling
stability of leadership directions
instructions from various
ministers escom is as old as modern
South Africa it was effectively created
in 1923 designed to Foster South
Africa's industrialization mine's still
making before 1994 escom had been
providing electricity to 98% of white
people but only 20% of black households
were connected to the grid escom and
thec did a remarkable job and they did
hook up something like 1.75 million
houses in less than 5
years when Mandela was released from
prison people were so happy we had that
thing that sat Africa is a bright future
so into the 1990s as democracy took hold
escom was still producing some of the
world's cheapest electricity but in this
very monopolistic system problems were
emerging as far back as 1998 a white
paper had said escom was going to reach
generation capacity by 2007 which it did
there were other spending priorities
there were huge social inequalities in
South Africa that needed to be addressed
and pouring money into old Power
stations did not really seem the top
priority from 1988 the ANC considered
but also procrastinated over making
escom and South Africa's energy Supply
more competitive at the same time
there's a countervailing for
within thec which looked at State
companies as escom as primary drivers of
the economy and also the engines to
create transformation to increase black
ownership so by the mid 2000s the
government had come to the conclusion
that yes it did need new generation and
so it decided to build two massive new
power stations mupi and cusil but from
the outset these contracts were hit by
delays overspend corruption and to this
day neither of those power stations has
ever worked properly because of the
anc's Socialist Heritage they were very
strongly opposed to the idea that
something as important as electricity
should be farmed out to the private
sector which was one of the ways that
electricity generation capacity could
have been improved and then you have the
wage of the Zuma years where the ANC
became a sort of cash cow for corrupt
politicians and Allied businessmen who
were connected to them I've been
vilified alleged to
be the king
of corrupt people the zondo commission
was an inquiry into something that
became known in South Africa as state
capture State institutions like escom
were hollowed out so in escoms case
somebody very close to Zumo was brought
in to run the company and contracts were
parceled out to friends colleagues to
people perhaps who had paid money to
thec and of course that all impacted on
the efficiency of escom added to its
debt and worsened the Gathering Power
crisis the corruption was very much at
the head but obviously what the head
does filters down what the Z inquiry
showed was that the the rot was pretty
much at every level maintenance esom was
neglected management turmoil at escom
was increasing and escom was also
becoming extremely resistant to an
initial boom in renewable energy outside
its control it's a bit like having heart
problems you'll have the buildup in the
arteries a long time before you have the
heart attack Android Dera was brought in
from the private sector to clean the
mess up Andre de's time at escom is in a
way a cautionary Tale about the
competing strands of the energy crisis
he was appointed by the ANC to fix the
rolling blackouts at the most intense
but also to lead the structural change
from a monopoly to separation to
restructuring to eventually a much more
open market for me taking on the job of
esom chief executive was an opportunity
to make a contribution to the country
either I had to turn it down and forfeit
my right to complain about South Africa
forever or roll my sleeves up and get
stuck in and try to be a part of the
solution I was taken back when I saw
some really appalling housekeeping at a
plant that was supposed to be the
flagship of escom this entire place was
was covered in fine cold dust wires were
hanging loose there were pieces of
equipment that had clearly been uh
operated until the point of breaking
down and then just being a band
abandoned so the entire impression was
one of neglect when DEA joined escom a
friend told him that he had just joined
the biggest criminal Syndicate in South
Africa he said I'll come on now when I
saw him several years later he said well
perhaps the guy was
right escom is a mega company so it has
a mega Footprints it has Mega budget
there were lots of ways to to to get
sort of your tentacles in that pot of
money if you consider anything that esom
might need to run a power plant that can
be very easily overpriced and so people
on the inside can help those on the
outside and in one very spectacular
instance I went into a plant and I was
shown some some knee pads we were paying
80,000 Rand for one so a pair would be
double that and we managed to affect an
arrest within 12 hours uh the individual
was released on the instruction of a
very senior police official who said
that there was insufficient
evidence another favorite Rose was to
deliver coal that had already been
discarded as unusable steal the good
coal and sell that abroad for a profit
the bad coal was then fed into the Mills
at escom Power stations they would often
grind to a halt needed to be fixed guess
by who by some of these very same
companies that were in a sense in
cahoots with people inside
escom so this plant to Tuka once had
been one of the top plants in esom when
I first visited I was taken AB back at
the state of the plant it was clear that
something was terribly wrong so we
appointed person from the outside a very
brave man called cell mcha and cell went
about dismantling the cartels that were
operating into Tuka but then the death
threat started and he had to walk around
on the plant with his bulletproof vest
tutuka was consuming about half of all
the fuel oil that escom burnt he
followed one of these trucks and figured
out that the truck was not offloading
but he was just round tripping over the
waybridge and generating an invoice
every time that there was a round trip
obviously with collusion from the
waybridge operator the security guard
and so
forth the other issue and this was the
legacy of State capture is that the
police the prosecutors and other key
institutions were also severely weakened
that put derter and his management team
in a very precarious position because in
order to tackle corruption they would
need to use private investigators it
didn't take long for the investigators
to uncover bombshell information they
identified no fewer than four criminal
cartels exploiting
escom my estimate was that at least a
billion Rand a month was being stolen
from escom and I think that's a
reasonably conservative estimate so
corruption has had a debilitating effect
on escom but I really want to emphasize
the critical mass of men and women at
escom are committed to the resolution of
this problem and I make the point when I
engage with them the best way of
redeeming ourselves is to ensure that we
we resolve the low shading problem and
we out those who are responsible for
acts of
corruption people trying to run a small
business can't protect themselves from
load shadding in the way that bigger
businesses can so load shedding deepens
inequality as
well I can work without electricity
without electricity I'm just
damned the only thing that it can help
me it's a generator and it's a small
business I don't afford a
generator I can't say I'm proud that I'm
CER fre because there's nothing that I
getting from my government you see cuz
there's a lot of struggle there's crime
there's
drugs oh I have four kids they can't
live here Alex is too dangerous it's too
toxic for a child to grow up in hence I
took them to the rural areas the crime
increases after the loate
increases I watch TV this side and then
uh this is the toilet in the
[Music]
bathroom all the friends that I grew up
with we were like maybe 10 now it's just
the four of us the six it's gone two in
jail two they smoking this drug they
call it so to
dead if like you have nothing to eat
obviously ly you don't have an option
but to tend to Crime there's no jobs
already plus the low chaing and all
microphone and it stars and B and
arrows so what does that
symbolize is freedom I want freedom I
want
Power if you look at the reality facing
millions of South Africans today there
is a huge underclass who are unemployed
and who cannot access not only jobs but
the education and the skills that they
want to access inequality is so high
it's not in such Stark racial lines
anymore because a lot of energy was put
into creating a black billionaire class
but it's still among the highest in the
world and this is an enormous risk to
South Africa's economic prospects and to
it social stability when the lights go
out crime goes up that could be petty
crime theft Bank robber is it could be
stealing cable and making power Cuts
worse next time round one of the very
unusual features of South Africa is that
alongside the police especially in
affluent areas there are private
security
companies we are in the alarm industry
here in South Africa looking after
residential and Commercial properties
the kind of area we driving towards now
is a commercial area lots of um we
houses factories and all that where
there is quite a lot of criminal
activity cable theft got theft there is
no electricity so it suits them because
there's no risk to them of getting shot
or
[Music]
electrocuted one substation like this
can carry electricity to look after
about 600 properties but the minute this
one gets vandalized a whole area goes
out all those cables are disconnected
there the
copper has been removed already often
feels like you're fighting losing battle
because you've got this box to protect
but it's another 1,400 in one area that
you have to look after it's actually a
kit if you're lucky enough to have them
in your surrounding and you do do hear
them getting noisy at night then you
must know there's something happening
like a outside alarm system that you
paying
[Music]
for hello security so an effect of load
sheding your gate motor starts
malfunctioning because the batteries
goes to low your gate don't close and as
you can see there's a vehicle there's a
generator at the back there's a little
mini bus that will be still in the eye
wi so I'm going to start heading to the
residential area where there's also load
shedding and see what's happening that
side you know a Pity criminal he will
jump your wall he will steal your
rushing he will steal a lawn mower he
will steal a leaf blower he will steal a
bicycle we were forced to start looking
at protecting solar panels as well solar
panels obviously goes onto your roof so
now there's a market for that there's
actually syndicates targeting those
houses they will come pretend to be
subcontractors pretend to be installers
if you find anybody in this industry
that says he's doing this for salary now
it's not it's a passion you want to be
out there looking after people reaching
out to people and just make it easier
for them on the end of the day the
government is the sole shareholder of
escom it appoints the board it appoints
the CEO there's been continued political
interference in the board and management
of Esco certain ministers were sort of
bypassing the board and making
unilateral decisions sort of opening the
door to dysfunction so the board too has
come and gone there have been
accusations of corruption incompetence
so escom by not attending to Ling is
actively agitating for the overthrow of
the state so even before he resigned d
had been accused of treason by South
Africa's energy Minister this simply
underlined how toxic political
interference in the management of escom
had become they didn't like him calling
the company a crime syndicate nor did
they like his emphasis on moving away
from coal to Renewable Power escom had a
revolving door of CEOs I know for a fact
that many people have been offered the
job as CEO of escom and have laughed
it's not particularly well paid if you
can't keep the lights on you're hated
and your prospects of keeping the lights
on are
minimal I mean when you are facing a
crisis of this nature you need
leadership stability and certainty and I
think it's regretable that it took us
over year for us to find a replacement
of a AO at escom anyone taking this job
knows it's going to be a pressure cooker
you could say a poison chalice in the
case of deoa it actually did end up
being literally ma when I got to the
office office uh the the coffee machine
had had apparently broken and um some
people were servicing this machine I
then eventually got served a cup of
coffee that that looked a bit off uh the
the the froth on top of the cappuccino
wasn't quite as nice as it usually was
but apart from that I noticed uh nothing
strange but then um after about 20
minutes I was sitting with a colleague
of mine I became very confused I was
feeling very nauseous I was sweating my
security detail rushed me off um to the
clinic where the doctor examined me did
all the usual checks then I um asked the
doctor to um run a tox screen it turned
out that the cyanide levels in my blood
were elevated so I guess it was a very
close shave uh and some people were
quite serious ious about getting rid of
me and uh happy to be here
today is
escom a a feeding trough if you like for
the
ANC I would say the evidence suggests
that it is deer had already resigned
when he effectively accused the ANC of
feeding at the trough of escom
corruption thec in turn blamed Dera they
said his job was to keep the lights on
and he had failed to do so those
allegations their veracity must be
tested before a court of law without
dismissing them the special
investigation units unit has been in
contact with the the former coo to
substantiate so that they get to build
the case if any and go after the
individuals who are found to be in the
wrong I'm proud to work for for esam no
other job in this country impacts the
entire 60 million people people with
that comes the pressure fix the problem
today to keep the lives on tomorrow and
for generations to
come the most important development
under rap's presidency has been a
recognition that escom can no longer
dominate South Africa's energy Supply so
escom itself is being separated into
generation and transmission to allow
more effective investment and management
of the power grid escom debts have also
been dealt with I think it's fair to say
that escom holds the fortunes of South
Africa in its hands because escom today
is over 400 billion round in debt and
half of that is backed by the government
and ultimately he has allowed another
boom in renewable energy this time from
private investment by removing red tape
and regulations that was holding this
back there were very strict limits as to
how much power a private company could
produce and what it could do with it the
cap on embedded generation was initially
lifted up to 100 megaw and then it was
abandoned completely in theory now a
private company can generate power at
whatever scale it wants to and provided
it can get it wheeled through the grid
which needs escoms permission it can
send that power to wherever it wants it
consumed in the country so almost at the
stroke of a pen we've started to make it
a more open competitive and
decentralized Market we have seen an
avalanche of private sector projects as
a result of the reforms that they've
been introduced on the generation
side the fact is that renewable energy
technology is now cheaper and faster to
deploy than conventional energy and in
particular uh when it comes to the
environmental impact of coal it is clear
that the that the choice has to be to
move to cleaner Greener sources of
electricity generation as quickly as
possible developed countries have begun
offering countries such as South Africa
billions of dollars of packages of
concessional loans grants to
decommission Co power stations and speed
up the roll out of Renewables so there
are sectors which are clearly going to
decline there are sectors in value
chains like like renewable energy
batteries electric vehicles these are
sectors that are going to Boom the
tradeoff of this boom in private
investment in Renewables is that it
risks advancing the death spiral of
escom by cutting off revenues South
Africa has some of the world's best
solar and wind resources the issue is
incentives would mean shutting down coal
mines it would mean putting coal
truckers out of work a lot of those
businesses are blackowned coal has been
one of the most successful businesses in
terms of the transition to Black
ownership the idea of a just transition
is to make sure that we manage those
social impacts in as planned and
responsible a way as possible the thing
to remember is that load shedding is not
the crisis itself and the crisis at its
roots is
political the anti-ip struggle was
fought in the mines ramapa was a mining
union leader that is the hint land of
many senior ANC politicians as the's
overall National majority comes into
question particularly in elections next
year it needs that support what are the
social impacts of not transitioning the
cost is too high we're going to be
permanently shut out of the global
trading system and we're going to lose a
lot of our export markets if the
developed world is interested in
encouraging uh Renewables to be a major
source of energy within the African
continent it should rather be providing
incentives and it should be working with
African countries by sharing
technology and uh making sure that
Africa can catch up with the rest of the
world esom now is effectively broke it
needs to invest primarily in
transmission lines because the new Power
will come from the Sun and the wind in
different parts of the country where the
transmission network is not yet fully
developed so they need billions and
billions of new investment to go into
that Unfortunately they don't have it
our own computation suggests that we
need 20 to $25 billion US for us to
strengthen and expand the grd by about
14,000 kilm in the next 10
years we don't have sufficient
generation capacity to meet
demand and government has taken a
decision to delay decommissioning by a
couple of years if you had to follow the
timelines for the decommissioning of
these power Stations between now and
2028 would have removed 9,000 megaw we
are short off about 3 to 4,000 megaw so
essentially the deficit will be 11,000
megaw I think the bottom line is this if
we can't stop load shading in 2 years
extending the life of the plant by to 10
years doesn't help because it's doing
more damage to the environment
escom provides something like 80% of
power to South Africa that number is
dipping in part because people are so
frustrated with load setting that
they're trying to get themselves Off the
Grid ShopRite is the largest retailer in
Africa its ambition is to be the most
affordable and accessible retailer uh in
Africa or we use around 5.5% of
renewable electricity and that's from
the solar PV panels that we have as well
as some of our landlords then there's
diesel as well diesel at the moment
probably represents between 15 and 20%
of the electricity that we
use so the group has more than 1,800
generators and those generators really
support the stores to be able to
function during times of load shedding
so it's automatically synchronized with
the mains so that it detects that the
supply has stopped there's a slight lag
about a minute before then the generator
starts and we're able to have
electricity in the store I think when it
comes to renewable electricity I think
the private sector is leading the way
for multiple reasons the first one to
decarbonize their operations secondly to
be resilient against low shedding and
thirdly to pay a lower price for
electricity the ShopRite group uses uh
Power purchase agreements with its
suppliers to install solar PV systems on
our roofs and we buy electricity
directly from the
suppliers
so the regulatory environment at the
moment is not conducive enough to
support the Wheeling of renewable
electricity Our concern is always that
the pace of change and the pace of
introducing these new regulations takes
a long time granted there's a lot of
let's say additional aspects and factors
to take into account because what
Wheeling would mean is that the income
that municipalities earn may be
compromised because you have bigger
business buying electricity from other
sources
South Africa already has some of the
lowest emission standards in the world
the issue is that as these Co power
stations can't be managed escom needs to
fill the Gap by allowing higher
emissions that involves a terrible
trade-off in terms of air
[Music]
quality we feel as communities that
there is a gap of Engagement while we
are in this area we are breathing toxic
air each and every day the sad part is
that we are bringing
up sick
generation suffering from these
illnesses hardship when breathing unable
to go full-time in
school they are getting old in a very
young
age my son who is now um 29 years
old I have seen him suffering a
lot
sometimes now we are at G power station
one of the biggest power stations in
South Africa Air does not have any
boundaries you know so everything that
that they do here we do bear the burdens
now for
me politics is around selfishness
greediness we were having a lot of
Hope but when time
goes I think you could use the fact that
traffic lights are off and things aren't
functioning properly as a metaphor you
know for who's at the driving seat in
South Africa it does sometimes feel like
there's no one at the steering wheel
load shading remains as an existential
threat to South Africa the sooner
government gets on top of this the
sooner esim gets on top of this the
better for the economy the better for us
to be able to create jobs where sun and
wind are different to Coal is that you
can't steal sun and wind and that is why
there is significant resistance to
transitioning away from the coal supply
chain this election is is crucial yes
it's very likely that thec will emerge
as the biggest party but it's also
perfectly plausible that it will lose
its absolute majority that it will not
be able to govern alone well it's for
posterity to judge whether our efforts
collectively have been effective and I
said the best measure of that is how
many hours of the day are your lights on
is there light in the dark yes I think
so the reforms that have been led by
Raposa to unleash private investment
will pay off in the next 2 to 3 years
but that may come too late for thec
itself South African voters are
Furious